[Music]
in gender confusion news submitted by
school is for fools youtuber Trisha
Paytas received massive backlash after
announcing that she is transgender oh
really she is such a good troll man why
can I see what she looks like you know
she has Steve I do I know Trisha I like
personally yes oh oh she's a master
troll everyone can [ __ ] off about Trisha
Paytas hate you will not I never took
her I didn't know people took her
seriously
so lots of people did oh so she's made
three videos around this so far and in
those videos like she's really really
cheerful and saying like I get it
I've done so many troll videos in the
past but this is like for real like how
I feel her thing this time it's I feel
not who I am yeah like she's explaining
it like this is how I felt my whole
mouth oh oh I see three years old she's
always felt like she's connected more to
like the male gender because she says
she has like a male energy and that but
she identifies herself as like a gay man
so so she likes men still so she still
likes men she actually likes gay men and
that she's she was saying in that first
video how she's she's kind of like like
a drag queen
where like she wants the attention when
she wants a like when she'll put on like
the hair in the glam and all that like
she loves that but when she chooses to
do that but recently she did this thing
where she dressed up as that guy fron
like in the photos that I was showing
you um she's a gay man so she says like
she feels the most comfortable like this
but her whole thing in that first video
too is saying that her so her whole
message is like pretty much a gift
you're feeling how I felt you're not
alone I don't she was saying that she
doesn't personally think that you have
to decide on a gender you don't have to
be either a female or a male for her
she's like some days I want to be a
female some days I want to
email links she's just like I feel very
it sounds like she's just talking about
when she wants to wear pajamas all day
or not am I wrong
she's she so then the second video or
the threat maybe she's trolling in this
video I do I think that she's a master
Tom this is what she looked like in that
first one um so then she in the other
videos or she's like really tearful
she's saying like you know she's she
feels really bad cuz she didn't mean to
offend anyone especially not the
community because people are saying like
like are you gonna dope about this and
people are literally like getting care
do dishes
trolling an apology video or no I was
good you know what just cuz you know her
do I think that what is she trolling an
apology video just cuz you know her I
mean dude she's up whatever she's up to
I don't there's no way I don't think
it's wrong I'd like it's gotta be
trolling cuz she's just such a so good
at it she's done it so many times so
well I remember she did this video where
she's like I love Mitt Romney Mitt
Romney's the best and she got [ __ ]
[ __ ] on like I've never seen before and
the chick knew exactly what she was
doing so I mean they're all crew they're
really good at getting attention I
really don't know how that is you know
any of that that is the most princess
person I've ever met in my life like
she's she is a Barbie store well she
said that um so growing up like she was
called a boy a lot and I guess she had
like flip hair or something that she
brings up and that she was just like
like you know so she was trying to like
overcompensate being girly to like kind
of convince herself that she felt good
and being girly and that's how she kind
of explained that well I guess what I'm
trying to get at is is she creating a
onion article that people are taking
seriously or are all of these things
just onion articles or is her apology
video finally a true video like a real
video I don't know but based off the
three videos that I saw like she seems
like to really try to harp and like I
get it like I'm not [ __ ] around this
time time I'm not [ __ ] around like I
really feel this way so but this is the
chick turn boy who cried wolf a million
and a half times is all
also a dancer yet she also addresses
that - she's I can't you know I know I
came on as by before like I know I came
out as like other things and stuff and
she's just like I just oh she also said
that she's been going to a gender their
gender identity therapist for the past
six months so she's been trying to like
figure out what it is that she's feeling
so in the end she didn't because
initially she says I'm Trent I'm
transgender female to male that's how
she initially titled it but then after
like the third video now she titled it
I'm questioning so now she doesn't want
to put a label on it she doesn't think
that she's gonna ever transition like
physically transition but that's just a
really kinda most interesting part of it
to me is she's a transgender male that's
gay right so then that means she has to
find a gay male that likes transgendered
a male who she talked about the hard it
would be to find a partner - yeah very
specific so that means like they're not
straight but they're gay but they like
vagina yeah they're gay but they like
biologically biological women yes what's
that called does she be named for that
I don't know anything yeah it's it's cuz
you it's like to me it's straight yeah
so good that you can't call it straight
the part of the first video that really
yeah and everyone off is this quote she
says do I think I'm transgender yes a
thousand percent do I identify with my
natural born gender a thousand percent
so then that part was just like you're
just making a big joke out of the whole
community is that how a lot of people
took it yeah I mean I think that yeah I
think that look I I don't I can't say oh
I'm speaking for Trisha Paytas here I
think that she's doing a bit but she
also maybe is confused about just her
own identity in general but I think
she'd do it fit you what about her a
crying video that did her due date you
think I think I see it but I mean I
think that she knows exactly she's doing
at all times I don't buy all this [ __ ]
that everyone always likes to go she's
so stupid she's airheaded dumb bimbo
[ __ ] all the [ __ ]
she's very smart very [ __ ] knows
exactly what she any one that's me like
really good online that's doing things
well I don't ever believe what they're
doing and how good is this by the way
this is [ __ ] that we're all sitting
hearing one like wait so that would be
this and you have to figure it this way
and isn't that just straight sex I mean
come on man like that that is a [ __ ]
master parity it's an episode of South
Park yeah mr. garrison that's what it is
I don't know if you guys know the
teacher he's gay and then he decided
that he's a woman but then he's a woman
that likes women women yeah so he's
straight I couldn't be more open-minded
about trans stuff but when it comes to
identifying parts of someone's body and
going this is a vagina when it's a dick
I'm just like whatever man you just do
your thing just do your thing and have
your labels and [ __ ] but you know what
it is what is clear though that people
should subscribe that's because whether
you're lesbian gay queer bisexual
transgender straight I don't know
whatever
everyone should subscribe because this
channel is for everyone and we
discriminate all equally so subscribe
baby I have a question I hope familiar
you guys with GG gorgeous she does
mention that GG had her up and said like
hey no one can tell you you're not a
transgender cuz that's how you feel
right yeah and then so she was like
crying and I apparently judy did a video
i didn't get to see it but she's in the
patricia ends up bringing her up and
saying like but the way you're saying
things i'm like fully transitioned like
people don't like that term cuz you
don't ever fully transition and then
like she was mentioning things like how
it's just the way trisha did everything
is which was really disrespectful to the
community um the way i bring her up
because i could be mistaken but just
from the little that I know is GG
gorgeous was biologically a man who
transitioned into a woman right full
transition I recently saw on the sidebar
one of her videos that says like why I
didn't know so she's not so I think she
still has like okay her male partner
then she just got I think she got
married but to a female right I don't
know who yeah transition into a male no
I think she's just a female yeah that
she might be queer I don't know what the
right term would be I don't know how she
identic her partner identifies G
gorgeous has titties though what's your
point
you just wanted to point that out well
cuz she's like if she had if she starts
a weird she kind of has both she got
Wiener and titties okay well I don't
know I like though just like this today
no just let you know what state she's in
oh okay yeah I guess so then I bring
that up to be like well maybe if it's
not a bit it makes sense because I guess
Gigi situation was like that if I'm not
mistaken I could be completely wrong but
I thought it was she changed she's she
has identified his female but then her
her the person that she married was
biologically female what's good like
Caitlyn Jenner how she did transition
like her whole body to be a female body
but she's she identifies as a lesbian
transgender cuz she likes girls also the
difference between her and GG is Brandi
well like so let's see if we take it
seriously and it's not a bit the
difference is for Gigi she is in the
process of transitioning right as she
has titties her she's saying that she's
this but she is not changing whatsoever
so at the end of the day it's a NetZero
transaction it's at the end of the day
it's just I'm still a girl that just
likes guys and the already very
convoluted way which makes it seems like
it could be a master bit and the
argument becomes I am just as trans as
anyone else which is what's so [ __ ]
ridiculous like oh yeah she got like
like a breast augmentation where she's
completely got you know this done yeah
she's taking hormones you know and then
she's like really passing as a dude that
would be
very different like this if Sacha Baron
Cohen came out and said I'm
transitioning who would believe him
that's where I'm at with this okay yeah
that's true that's all I'm saying it's
just about it's just about your public
persona what you've earned and like who
you are it's hard to believe it's
impossibly I believe impossible but if
it did come out it starts bawling his
eyes out I'm so sorry about Borat or
nobody would believe him still no it
would be part of the bit he's done that
[ __ ] for years like he did but he did
Borat for a year a year as like Borat :
it's like okay cool you think I'm the
troll fine I'm at rolling your eyes I've
earned that um she doesn't identifies at
all anymore
but that's why I know she's trolling but
then so Jon's at Troy so she ends up
saying like the reason why she's still
making videos about it is because she's
really hurt that she hurt the community
oh is that they like rejected her when
she's always been like an ally and like
she feels part of the community and so
that's the whole point of like her doing
an apology and then saying that she's
questioning because she she's like I
don't care if you believe me or not this
is how I feel and I just wanted to put
it out there in case I could help
someone else that is that's feeling
lonely because her main thing was like
I'm lonely if you're lonely let's be
lonely together and like she's just very
like trying to connect with her audience
so I don't know she could be a master
troll but from what I saw like out of
those three videos I could seem like she
was pretty genuine that's why she's such
a good troll and listen and I say that
with all was the respect in the world I
think she's a great role I think she's
funny as [ __ ] and I loved her spada's
him or her
[Music]
[Music]